hey there
thanks for tuning in to this pi data
talk my name is massimiliano
and i'm speaking to you from the
netherlands i'm currently a data
scientist at
tomtom which is a location navigation
and map technology company here
but in a previous life i was a physicist
and a mathematician
and so there's still a little bit of
mathematician in me and i
love finding out about some you know new
little tools or
different ways of explaining things uh
you know from the life of a data
scientist
and today i'd like to tell you about one
of these tools
that i came across some time ago and i
also managed to apply a couple of times
uh this is called quantile regression i
guess no surprise because that's the uh
that's the title here today um but what
i was surprised about
is that it doesn't seem to be so well
known in the machine learning of data
scientist communities
even though it could be really useful um
so when we're finished today i hope to
have given you enough
information or of an impression to
recognize the situations in your work
where some of these techniques are
applicable
[Music]
so it's mostly about getting some level
of intuition
and understanding what this is for what
it's all about and not necessarily to
understand
every detail about it so in other words
i hope that at the end
you know what quantum regression is that
it exists
and you might have some feeling of when
to try it out
now to ease you in
we'll start with a hypothetical
situation so
let's say i'd like to sell a house but
i do not know anything about real estate
so in particular i have absolutely no
idea about
prices you know how much should i
try to sell it for i would be terrible
at the negotiation without any
information
so i need a broker so i go to a broker
and i say
hey broker how much should i expect to
get
if i put my house up for sale
they might say something like well a
place like yours will usually go for
around
180k
um all right so they're saying something
like a place like yours so they're
taking something into account about
some aspect of my place maybe the area
or the type of type of house
and they're saying we'll usually go for
a round so that can
mean a lot of things that's kind of
ambiguous but probably it means
something like
you know an expected value with the like
yours being some
size or something so
probably it's some kind of expected
value
but wait do i just want to get an
average price or do i want to get a
really good deal so if i
sell i want to make as much of course as
possible
so i might phrase it differently okay so
what would be a great deal so like
what what should i be really happy if i
managed to uh
sell it for that um and they might say
something like and i would hope that
they would phrase it something like this
although there's probably not very very
realistic they could say something like
a house like that sells for less than
200k
about 90 percent of the time or
equivalently sells for more than 200k
about
10 percent of the time
okay so what does this really mean
right so there is a part of a house like
that so there is some
some taking into account some aspects of
this house so some features
and then there is something about 90 of
the time
it goes for less than 200k so that is a
statement about percentiles or quantiles
those are the same thing by the way so
these are used interchangeably
so if i managed to sell it for 200k
that's a good deal
for me all right how good 90th
percentile good
right so it's kind of grading on a curve
[Music]
okay let's say that our broker was very
mathematical
um or that they had some kind of model
to back them up
how could they get to such a number
all right so to think about that
let's start with the situation where we
know
absolutely nothing yet about the house
so we don't know how big it is we don't
know what kind of house it is
then what is the best we can do well the
best we can do is basically the naive
thing
which is just plotting a histogram
and looking at the shape of the
distribution and the thing we can say
well
ninety percent of houses in general sell
for less than two hundred eighty
thousand
[Music]
all right so that is a quantile
statement right so it's a it's a
statement about the 90th quantile you
can plot it here and this
in this purple line
but that's pretty lousy because look at
all those mansions there on this long
tail
these are really expensive houses you
you know probably these houses are just
really big or something and that's why
they're
selling for more or they're in a really
good location
so you might think okay let's see if we
can break this down by the type of house
now what if my house my house is a
duplex then i might want to know
you know uh what is the price such that
90
of duplexes sell for less than that
number
now that's exactly what a box plot does
right so a box plot
is uh is a plot to plot categorical
values
against some continuous variable
and to get some visual inspection about
quantiles for lots of different types at
the same time
[Music]
okay by the way worn out watch out there
is not really a uniform definition of
what these whiskers so these these
little
balls at the end should really mean
um but you can use this uh to to set it
for example the end of the whiskers at
90th percentile and then you can read
off
all right if it's a two family if it's
the tumor family house for example you
can expect to get
this much and in 90 of the cases it will
be less than
this amount all right that's already a
lot better than what we had previously
but it's still not that great because
you can see here that there is still you
know it's not that much information the
spread basically it's very big
and you know there could be an
another correlation with some other
aspect for example
it's well known that size matters in the
pricing of real estate
so what about the size of the house
well one way to measure the size of the
house is of course the the area of the
living space
and you can say as you start by plotting
the continuous variable against the
continuous variable of the area so the
square footage or square meters against
the price that the house
sold for
initially i wouldn't even be really
clear about how to formulate the
equivalent of this 90 percent
of the place itself or less than blah
blah blah
it would be something vague like 90
percent of the places with a similar
surface area where similar is not well
defined so
you would need to do some boxing
sorry some some grouping there
how should you formulate it well
i guess the first thing people would do
is just draw a line through it you know
using a regression
but that doesn't really get you that far
because
it doesn't tell you about the the
variance part there
unless you explicitly also take that
into account and in a lot of cases
this is not really the right thing to do
so we want to
have something that is specific about
the
quantiles conditional on the area
now even though it's not so clear how to
phrase the question the answer you
already know
should look something like this like
this purple line here so i don't know
what the question is but the answer is
going to look like this line
because when you expect here inspect
here for example a house of an area
of 2000 i think this is a square feet
then the average or the expected price
that it sells for
is is this here and the
90th percentile is here and you can see
that about 10
of the similar houses will lie above
here and 90
will lie below the line here okay so
that is roughly what we mean
that brings us to the actual topic and
that is
the mathematical way of asking
the right question there that ends up
drawing that purple line
so how do you draw this line what does
this line mean
and i think also pretty importantly how
do i not do this just for one feature
like the area but how do i do it for a
bunch of features at the same time
maybe even non-linearly or you know
something fancier if i want to now
this whole example of course was made up
but
there are also some real applications of
this uh of this way of thinking in
literature and this whole applica
this whole area started out in economics
and social sciences
where for example one of the uh
one of the things to look at there is uh
food spend versus income so this is
something that already
karl marx and engel were doing uh you
can
you know you you see that there is this
heteroskedastic effects
of uh the variance in the foodspend
not being constant in the income for
example not even if you take log linear
scales in both
so similar techniques can be used to
look at unemployment rates
or what i think is a nice hypothetical
example i haven't seen it in
literature is thinking about student
potentials
so given the background of a student so
for example maybe something about social
economic status which is known to
to have a big influence in what you can
expect
but also maybe previous grades or some
other conditions
to see if you can identify what is the
maximum potential
of a certain student and maybe reward
them if they if they are going above
that or something like that of course
i'm not saying anything about the ethics
of that but you can imagine doing
something like that
now what is also found in the literature
is demand forecasts and i think this is
the first place where it showed up in a
more serious way
where i'm expecting it's making some
money somewhere
and this is in the energy sector so
there is a whole industry of predicting
supply and demand
for managing a grid
because what you need to do is to know
about the peak loads that
might happen so the peak demand for
example
to plan your supply so you need to
forecast demand in order to
create supply or the other way around if
you want to set prices
and if you want to do this and manage
risk
you need to know about things like all
right
so 99
of the time i want to overestimate
otherwise i will have a shortage
of electricity of power
so statements that you can get then are
related to that risk which makes it
unquantifiable right so
at the 99th percentile this means you
will underestimate one percent of the
time
so if this is an hourly forecast it's
once every 100 hours
you might have not enough energy all
right
but minimizing the
wasted capacity all right so this is a
construct kind of a constraint
optimization problem now just nice to
note
that there is some open benchmark data
set
and that is what a lot of papers were
based on and it turned out
that when it comes to demand forecast of
electricity
some neural net methods that work with
this quantile regression
sort of work quite well for this and it
gives you all kind of a lot of paramet
non-parametric information
about the distribution of this demand
now the last example i want to highlight
is called
is wallet estimation and that's quite
similar to what we talked about with the
house prices
so ibm noticed that they had a lot of
data about
uh what the the sizes of deals that they
had with different
clients but their sales team knows that
when you know
in a negotiation what the potential
spend is so for example the entire i.t
budget of a company
you're in a much better position to
negotiate because you know you know what
is the ceiling
now you can imagine the only thing you
observe in the data is what people
actually spend and what you want to know
is the potential spend so this is a
one place to apply is quantile
regression so thinking about for example
the 80th percentile of spent
all right enough about applications now
show me some mathematics
so let's put this quantum regression
into context
by contrasting it to some things that
might be more familiar
and i think the most familiar to people
will be ordinarily squares which is here
all the way on the left
and what ordinary least squares does is
the least squares right is
minimizing the squared error loss that's
one way of defining it
but what is really the goal what is this
thing estimating it is estimating
the conditional mean right so
f here me is the um
is the distribution density
and we have conditioned here this
distribution
on the value of the features so for
example the
features of the house so the area and
the type of building and then we want to
know something about the conditional
mean so expected value
of the output of this
all right so that's called l2 regression
also sometimes now l2 regression you
shouldn't be confusing
with l2 regularization so please
keep that in mind but it feels a little
bit arbitrary because why this squared
loss it doesn't really seem like the
thing
you would naturally want to minimize and
something like
the difference of the absolute value
seems a little bit more natural to some
people
and in fact there is such a thing that's
called mae or l1 regression
and it's sometime also called you know
the regression that's robust to outliers
um but to make that more precise
actually you can show that minimizing
this mae
is the same as or implies estimating the
conditional median
so this notation here is a little bit
more complicated
but this capital f here is the
cumulative distribution function
then you invert that so that means if
you invert the cumulative distribution
function
what goes in is kind of a probability
threshold
and what comes out is a value in the
domain of
y which is your output value of a model
right so that's
a little bit complicated but so inverse
of that
evaluated at one half because the median
is
is the mid the middle of the value so
it's the
value of y such that half the values
are going to be below that
okay now we are finally ready to say
what quantile regression really is
that is estimating the conditional
quantile so we take the same inverse of
cumulative
distribution function so conditioned on
feature x and we try to find the value
at
alpha where i'll find some value between
zero and one so for example
alpha 0.9 is trying to find the 90th
percentile or the good deal
okay then we need some kind of
equivalent here
for the loss function so what is the
equivalent
here well since this is a
generalization of this also the pinnable
loss probably should be a generalization
of the
mae error
so let's see what we can do there
um we want to generalize this here the
mean absolute error and if you plot that
that is this here right so it's
x equals x and it's the opposite here on
this side
and the idea here is to take that plot
and take a different penalty for
overestimation
and underestimation and that boils down
to
tilting it one way or the other and you
can see that here in the plots
so for example estimating the 75th
percentile
it's the same as tilting it is tilting
this graph
this way and applying this loss function
so if you want to write that out instead
of case notation it looks like this you
can also do it using indicator function
for example
so different penalty for over and
underestimation that's the basic idea
and that's called pinball loss it's also
sometimes called tilted loss because
you're taking the loss and
tilting it
now that's nice that's the definition
but it doesn't tell us that it's going
to work
so how do we know that this is the right
thing well
what does it even mean to do the right
thing there so what i want
to see is what does minimizing this loss
function have to do with finding the
quantile we want to show some kind of
equivalency
and one way sort of ignoring the
conditional part is to formulate it like
this
so we have a minimization part here on
the left and we have this
inverse conditional distribution
function on the right
so we want to say basically
mathematically
that minimizing expected value of
certain loss
is actually finding this thing
okay well
you can sketch a proof like this so it
has a it has a couple of steps maybe it
looks a little
intimidating to people who are not used
to this type of thing
but the ingredients are really not so
bad so there is a couple of ingredients
here
and they have to do with uh you know
things like uh this uh distribution
theory and
liveness rule product rule a couple of
things like that
and i think it's not really appropriate
for uh for this conference talk so if
someone wants to talk about that we can
do that in the q a and i'll be happy to
uh
to explain the steps but let's instead
go for an easier route we'll go
proof by picture of a special case and
the special case very conveniently
is the mean absolute error which we said
earlier
is supposed to find you the median
okay how can we see this let's say i
want to take the elevator
and there's a bunch of elevators in a
row and i'm not sure which one will come
first
i'm lazy so i want to minimize the
distance that i walk to this elevators
where should i stand with respect to the
elevators now if there's two
it doesn't matter as long as i am
somewhere in between
because no matter where i stand
there's of course a one and two chance
because i don't know anything about how
the elevators come that i have to go to
the one
and to the other so the sum of these is
always going to be the same
[Music]
now if there's three after you think
about it for a while it's actually
it gets more important where you stand
you should stand in front of that middle
elevator
okay if there's four again it doesn't
matter so much as long as i stand in
between the two middle elevators and you
can hear
now how this minimization problem of
how long do i expect to walk is
equivalent
to standing in the middle of the between
the middle elevators
so that's the median okay
so that's a proof by picture of why this
uh
mean absolute error has to do with the
medium
all right so we're curious now we need
to step out of the world of math and
into the real world
so we need some kind of implementation
to get
numbers out
an easy way to do this is to use for
example python page of stats models or
the
r equivalent of that if we want to use a
linear version of this quantile
regression
um you know it's the original it's where
economics
use these techniques and in fact it's
also what i used to draw this purple
lines in the housing example
but maybe we're not so happy with just
linearity
we want to do something fancier with
more you know more options more
tunability and
we could go for some gradient boosting
method because
uh a lot of the gradient boosting
methods what they mostly need
is some kind of you know some kind of
function that we want to minimize
uh with some conditions and in fact
that's what scikit-learn and light gbm
do
they take just this pinball loss or a
smooth or smoothened out version is also
possible
and just a hand calculated
gradient and you can do your thing
now something similar will also work for
neural nets and that's i'm going to show
you in a bit
but there's a lot of other ways of doing
it also so for example you can
you can generate three methods or
nearest neighbor methods kernel methods
the basic idea for most of these is that
you just use the math
the method for regression to find sort
of the conditional distribution
and then you take a local quantile
there's also a really great trick in the
literature about how to reduce this
problem to classification problem
but that is not always feasible
[Music]
all right so what if i want to use
tensorflow or keras to implement such a
model
because for some reason i think
that gradient boosting is not going to
be good enough or
maybe i have this time series data or
something
turns out it's not so difficult so this
uh implementation you see here it's not
super long
and the real meat is just in this line
here
right so we have y true minus y
predicted and then we have some kind of
maximum and some uh average and that's
it now it takes maybe a bit of thinking
to see that this is equivalent
to the other formulation but it is so
that's not so bad right
so this is easy
and what is one of the benefits it's
actually that you can have
multiple different quantiles with
different outputs at the same time
so you can take a median a 90th
percentile and a 99th percentile all
part of the same model
optimizing for them at the same time
the challenge then on the other hand
becomes how to balance these
different outputs that's always the case
when you have multiple outputs in one
model
because there's you can always only
minimize one thing
so probably you can take the sum or a
weighted sum you have to think about it
now let's say we've made such a model
how do we evaluate it
because there is one thing that is
slightly trickier than with usual
regression and that is
evaluation so just like with the
unsupervised methods
it can sometimes be difficult to know
how you're doing
because you're not observing the value
that you're actually predicting
right so what can we do
well the first thing to do for sure is a
sanity check
because if we're saying that our model
predicts 90th percentiles
we'd better only be uh
we'd better only be underpredicting uh
by
10 percent or in 10 of the case but that
cannot be the full story because that
would mean
that the population quantile would
optimize
would be the optimal solution to the
problem and that doesn't make sense
so we also apply our usual methods
of train test validation maybe some
k-fold cross-validation
to compare different versions of the
model to see how much better one is
against the other probably you still
want to have some kind of evaluation of
how fit for purpose
is this model for whatever the thing
you're trying to use it for
so you might also need some expert
judgment or some other things
and another evaluation method is
winkler's course
we can talk about it in q a session if
someone is interested in that
now i hope i gave you enough so far so
that
when you leave you have at least the
following
you can identify when you know if you're
interested
in some kind of potential value or risk
right so you're making a prediction
about extreme values
or you know some kind of grading on a
curve
you know that at least one of the
options you have is quantile regression
now the other thing i'd like to take
away is that when you're predicting
bounds
and let's say you're not interested in
this quanta regression directly
but if you're predicting something that
sounds like a quantile you have an
evaluation method to compare two
versions of your model
or else being equal which one predicts
the bounce best
and that metric is pinball metric
okay so that was all for me for now
and i hope to see you at the q a
session thanks and stay safe